I also had a very first Geeks plus
office Christmas party the other day
which was a lot of fun you missed the
beginning of that I did I did yeah I was
so I think I think the highlight of that
like of that night because I've been
thinking about it ever since that night
was uh we had like a secret Santa right
so we had we had a Secret Santa you know
everyone exactly everyone got some nice
gifts and everyone but I I forgot there
was someone who bought uh what was it
what was that like [ __ ] sorry Kendama
yeah yeah yeah like a kendama like
Japanese toy and
there was a revolution that that like
that like opened my mind to be like I
didn't realize something so simple could
be so much [ __ ] fun holy [ __ ] it was
like I forgot who actually got it for
the for the yeah that's yeah that's
right diet has got it for a present who
gave it to Dougie ah I think Anna did
right oh Anna did yeah Anna gave it to
dieters for the president and it was you
know it's just like a small little
Kendama and and Titus was like what is
this and you know someone had to show
him how to do it by the end of the night
there was like at all times at least
seven people just in a semi-circle
surrounding them being like me next
it's just it just made me realize damn
kids in the 1950s had it [ __ ] good
man holy [ __ ] who needs a [ __ ] iPad
who needs [ __ ] fortnite when we have
like a [ __ ] Kendall when you get
cracked in it then it's no longer fun
because you can do it every time no
because then you start to learn like the
special tricks and they'll just take
like years to perfect I'm good I'm good
okay honestly I've been thinking about
getting one myself I'm just a literal
children's toy it's actually so fun you
know because like initially you look you
don't know you haven't tried it
initially I know what it is I've used it
yeah initially you look at it and you're
like this is this is [ __ ] stupid I
mean you try once you're like I'm trying
to go I'm gonna try it again I'm going
to try it again and and it's it's got
like that perfect I'm gonna call it like
a gameplay Loop of just like just one
more time one more time I'll get it this
time I'll get it this time Joey is
[ __ ] crack today because he he Joey
showed us the Strat and I think that's
what made it like so much fun because we
could see what we needed to do so the
stride is just like you have to pull up
you have to pull the string up at like
the perfect amount of like strength like
directly vertical like directly vertical
and you need to [ __ ] just like
perfectly land it on the Kendama and so
they're like four stages of difficulty
so they're like there's like uh if you
know his here's what it looks like on
screen right so you got like three
appendages uh and each appendage has
like a uh cup that is a different kind
of size
um and Joey did it like so the smaller
the smaller the size the harder it is to
land it on that cup and Joey like Joey
tried to do it Joey showed us to do it
on like the hardest difficulty setting
and everyone's like that looks easy I'm
just gonna go for the hardest difficulty
setting right off the bat a quality
setting of your kids toy yeah yeah and
uh yeah and then we like I think a group
of like [ __ ] seven of us wasted two
hours just watching this ball go [ __ ]
up and down it was
it was the hypest thing to happen when
anyone got it the first time everyone
was just like oh oh literally you showed
me how to like spin it and oh yeah
I told people how to do it on like the
spike like to get the hole on the spike
which is the hardest one and I did it
and I did a first go and even I was
surprised I was like oh [ __ ] and then
everyone was like yo let me try that and
for like the next two hours everyone's
just trying to do it what gift did uh
you guys supposed to both give and
receive uh so I didn't find out that we
were doing a secret santa until
literally like two hours before I was
supposed to show up right mailing was
like by the way we're doing a secret
santa I wasn't here for this because I
was on a plane yeah it kind of was on
his way back from the US right so so
mailing texted me like two hours before
I was supposed to show up being like by
the way we're doing a secret santa no
pressure though I was like why are you
telling me this you'll end the loop if
you don't yeah exactly so I was just
like well [ __ ] I don't have time to go
out to shop for something let alone wrap
it up so I just gotta like grab
something from home and so I just was
like all right I I guess if any if
everyone's kind of doing like joke gifts
or whatever and like not serious gifts
then I'll just I'll just give a joke GIF
so I just grabbed my copy of uh tf's tsf
monogatari by Shin Noel and just wrap
that [ __ ] up yeah and placed it and then
of course out of all of the people who
had to grab my gift there were about 40
40. yeah those are like 30 or 40 people
there yeah I had a 1 in 30 to 40 chance
that Sydney would grab my gift and she
grabbed my gift oh well and I was like
this was it all just like a free-for-all
you just grabbed a gift you didn't have
a person
we had a system I don't know why mainly
did it in the most arbitrary system I've
ever seen in my life yeah like we were
we were we had like we used up like 20
to 30 minutes figuring out a system and
I don't you just normally just go online
and type everyone's names in then it
tells you who you're buying a gift for
you put everyone's name into a website
and it'll be like gone is your Secret
Santa oh and they'll get the same thing
oh I always used to do it for me it was
always just like okay there's you know
all the presents are at the bottom of
the tree right yeah yeah and then it's
just a free you just go up and ground no
it's more fun to know who you're vying
for and then but then if it doesn't
become a Secret Santa no it's secret
because you don't know who's buying for
you you never know who's buying for you
so this uh well I don't know if it's
different because this was called like
white elephant so I don't know if the
rules are different I mean the only
thing I know is secret santa why
elephant it's basically the same thing
but you just it's kind of like more of
like you buy a random gift that you put
into the pool and then yeah like all the
gifts are randomized and you kind of
like pick you don't know who you're
buying for you don't know so we came up
like Malin uh being the mom came up with
this like [ __ ] overly complicated
system where she was like how many
people bought gifts everyone put your
hands up right now okay we're all gonna
start we're all going to assign you a
random number and everything like that
and and so we spend like 20 minutes
trying to figure out the system and Joey
just goes wouldn't it be what's stopping
us from just everyone taking a random
gift I mean it's like no no no we cannot
do that we need the numbers we need the
numbers and so I had so we all had to
wait for meleen to like write like on
each individual note [ __ ] pad just be
like write a number and then like put it
in a bag and then everyone pick it out
and then calling the number like I was
like I was at the [ __ ] Ward office I
was just like waiting for my number
oh my God it's like welcome to the DIA
Japan DMV this is exactly so Sydney got
your gift Sydney got my gift and oh and
I was like no all right come on Sydney
just replace it with someone because
like that's just that's a lame present
for you right like you probably already
have a copy of that so she gave it to
Martha instead yeah
um you know he enjoyed it yeah
um and then I got uh I forgot who bought
it for me I got seki hung which is like
the the red rice oh you know that so in
Japan there's this thing which is called
sticky hands red rice and traditionally
you cook it like parents cook it for
their daughters when they hit puberty
oh that's nice yeah wait wait wait what
think about that wait why
because they're on their period for the
first time
they get them red rice they give them
red rice because they hit that period
I'm not joking that is a tradition
that's been going on and someone was
like I'm a bite that's like that's like
me taking my first [ __ ] and you just
give me like brown rice
just like oh great oh no my first fecal
excretion I get to have some food that
reminds me of it yeah so I got I got
that I got a steaming pile of that
um
congratulations on getting your period
Joey I'll be good yeah I'm sure it
tastes great I'm now a fully grown maybe
it'll last until you get a daughter
[Music]
I'll just hold on to it being like I got
this 30 years ago from a Christmas but
holding on to this is there any other
like Japanese Traditions like that
because I know there's like the coming
of age kind of like
um ceremony right uh the drink which one
right you just drink you just drink you
just get [ __ ] faced is that what is it
that that is all you do you do drink
yeah I mean there's all that situation
worldwide baby yeah there's also uh
which is like it's this ceremony that
you do when your child turns either
three five or seven oh yeah I've heard
this
um and uh and I don't know exactly what
happens in it because I I never did it
um but both Childs are boys
they're crazy no I think it can be
either gender right yeah there's a boy's
boy thing right as well it's like a boy
celebration something I can't [ __ ]
remember what it is the penis fist not
the not the penis vessel what's the
thing when you put the you put the
little fish out the fish uh oh
nobody that's there that's uh children's
day oh maybe children yeah that's May
the fifth and we we for some reason we
we we we we put up these like huge uh
koi like the koi fish yeah decorations
and we put them on like a top of a
flagpole and it's just kind of as like a
mock-up flag I don't know what this
resemblance there's a lot of things in
Japan there's a lot of weird holidays
like that in Japan there's also
hinamatsudi which is like the little
dolls as well children as well
um yeah I don't know lots of lots of
celebrations for children
has a child because they had a
population they have none so they're
like yeah it's just like uh we don't
know what to celebrate
[Music]
it's a momentous occasion when someone's
like oh you desire to have kids in Japan